in the studio we've got Chris Butler
Stroud who is the chief executive of
whale and dolphin Conservation and Erik
van sable who's oceanographer at
Imperial College London and from Weston
super Mare we're joined there by
governor al bear who's UK manager of the
charity Project Aware don't know let's
start with you if we can
down there in weston-super-mare project
- where what do you try to do with that
what what's the awareness that you are
trying to develop so Project Aware is a
global marine conservation charity we
work mainly but not exclusively with
scuba divers and we activate them to
take action in their local community we
have a citizen science program where we
collect marine debris data but from
underwater so we bring a complete
different perspective to the global
marine debris crisis collecting data and
quantifying the quantity the amount and
type of debris ice found underwater and
Chris when it ends up underwater it
becomes a problem for species that
you're interested in talk to us about
the kind of impact it's happening
well we're beginning to see plastics
throughout much of the oceans and we
we're just at the beginning of the
impact and that's the real message and I
think why this campaign by Sky is so
important it's it's not just what the
plastic is out there it's actually the
tidal wave of plastic that's coming and
we're beginning to see happen so for
example we've seen fin whales the second
largest animal that's ever lived on this
planet with lacerations inside the
animal from plastics from DVD cases we
saw a stranding last year of sperm
whales off the European coast including
the UK and four of those animals had
plastic sheeting and plastic bags
blocking their feeding areas if there's
no question about having a neutral a
benign effect it's it's potentially
killing them it's potentially killing
them and in some cases we believe it
really is killing them when it's leading
to further deaths the build-up of micro
plastics and other plastics we're really
just at the beginning of all that and I
think we're beginning to see it's coming
through in the research there's only
initial stages of it but this is most
probably a fair representation of what
really is to come in terms of what we're
going to face
marine life eric pensively in terms of
prevention rather than cure
we'd rather do prevention wouldn't we
because we don't have a way of curing
this problem least not yet absolutely
there's so much plastic in the ocean
right now as you said 8 million tons
every single year and that is just
coming in and a really scary thing is
that we can account for only 1% of all
the plastic on the ocean 99% of all the
plastic that's out there we don't know
actually where it is it could be on the
ocean floor it could be on our beaches
it could be in the stomach's of whales
and other and that's it everything
seemed to be hotspots don't that with
inner oceans
yeah in areas where the tide is cold is
concentrating and massing this stuff
yeah so what the ocean is doing is it's
constantly moving around to plastic so
if you get a bottle like this and you
throw it in the ocean here from say
Somerset or so then it doesn't stay
there it goes around with the currents
and as it goes the waves and the Sun
break it down into smaller and smaller
pieces and these pieces they get LJ
start growing on them and that weighs
them down so they start slowly sinking
the other thing that the alligator of
course is that fish come along and think
that it is a piece of algate rather than
a piece of plastic so that's a big
source of enough of fish eating it it's
just mistaken a piece of plastic the
crystal camp aiding perspective you
really get the opportunity to view this
in the sense that you were appealing
directly to people's and sense of
enlightened self-interest you know you
can talk about what's happening to blue
whales and most of the time that feels a
fairly abstract concept to most people
when you say actually it applies to the
fish that you eat they see a direct
connection with their own health right
absolutely
but the whales and the Dolphins
basically act as the alarm call for us
we're beginning to see things happen to
them which we will also see happen to
humans at some stage so 20 years ago we
saw things like PCBs starting to be
dumped into the oceans and we started to
see those coming into marine species
being concentrated in the blubber being
passed on to their calves we're seeing
now those same things
acting with plastic as vectors being
taken into other animals including human
beings and you're right
humans have to realize that protecting
the marine ocean isn't just about
protecting wildlife there will be
something about protecting themselves as
well which would be a benefit let's just
go back to Donna Albert
at Western super med doable oh are we
absolutely definitively 100% certain
that when it comes to how long it takes
to degrade a plastic bag a plastic
bottle the stuff what we've got it here
in our studio today we are talking about
decades actually we're talking about
hundreds of years are we absolutely sure
that's true what we're leaving in a
throwaway Society but what new thing
twice a way doesn't exist so when
somebody throw away a plastic bottle and
that blasting bottle makes its way to
the ocean plastic doesn't biodegrade it
fragments into tiny pieces of plastic
which is called micro plastic and and
and it it go away it doesn't exist so we
have to think twice when we throw away
plastic because it doesn't go away that
is in a sense part of the problem that
the fact that you've got this enormous
in terms of the physics of the thing
this enormous force kinetic energy
exerted by the Seas in terms of that
grinding action and actually when you
see what it does to a beach you think
wonderful when you see what it takes a
large piece of plastic turns into a
smaller piece of plastic making it
easier to be mistaken by sea life then
you realize you've got a problem yeah
and of course there's no way that you
can clean up the small small particles
if you find a plastic bottle like this
on a beach then anybody in your right
mind would pick it up and actually
collect it and that's something new you
can actually do at home or on your beach
walk to clean up the problem because the
thing is of course that something that's
on the beach the next storm will take it
back out to sea so on the beach is not
away from the ocean it's just
temporarily there if that that is where
you take it out then you actually save
the ocean but you can only do that with
big pieces of plastic you can't see if
the entire beach you can't see through
the sand because most of the plastic
particles the micro plastic they're so
small you won't even be able to
recognize them on the sand Chris a lot
of the projections that
environmentalists get involved in our
guess work but we are pretty sure
because we know rates of consumption are
what they are that we will get to around
about 2050 and in terms of weight
there'll be more of this stuff in
see them there will be fish life itself
yeah this is absolute ruin if we look at
even the danube in austria at the moment
we've got more plastic than we do have
fish larvae in that river so that the
information that's coming through in
terms of the impacts would write on the
beginning of in terms of how much is
there we know that we're producing more
plastic than the weight of human beings
every year now we know that we're having
about eight million tonnes go into the
oceans projections are saying that could
be one hundred plus million tons by 2050
we are standing at the cusp of the
disaster which we can do something about
we we're late on certain issues like
climate change on this if we take action
we have government action we have
business we have consumers we have
groups working together then we can
really do something about it and i think
we can prevent that from happening in
2050 w al bear when you talk to people
down there a western super Mare further
afield of parts of the work the west
country are you pushing at an open door
is this a subject that people are
getting their heads around and beginning
to understand that action is required
well for most people
marine debris is very much out of sight
out of mind and that's why the work that
discover divers are doing to show the
underwater perspective of the problem is
very important
seventy percent of plastic sink on the
seabed
so with divers showing this underwater
perspective of the global crisis we can
show striking photos and we also can
share data with other group other groups
focusing on on beach cleanups and
encourage people to take action and for
people not living by the sea it's very
easy to think that it's not for them but
eighty percent of marine debris comes
from land so changing behavior and
tackling the problem at source is very
very important we need to prevent marine
debris to make its way to the ocean
because when it gets to the ocean its
kind of too late the damage is done so
we need to show the data share the data
work together with other groups partner
ways
stakeholders industry leaders the
government to find solution we can all
take action as individuals to make a
difference and it starts with with
reducing plastic being more aware of the
plastic assumption that we have say no
to plastic Stroh's easy steps that will
all contribute towards solutions and and
we need to find solutions now before we
get to a no turning point era Guinea
don't ever get an interesting point in
the sense that you know you've got an
individual decision you could make about
whether you really need to use that
plastic straw or whether you just use
you wash up the cup and use the cup
you've already made clear this is this
is not a problem that you can be
parochial about you throw something ends
up in the sea loft weston-super-mare
years later it ends up somewhere on the
other side of the world there are parts
of the developed world which are going
to be using more and more and more of
this stuff perhaps the rate of increase
market greater they're getting
population changes and it is in the
Western world but this is ultimately the
ultimate global problem isn't it it is
and it connects us all because the ocean
doesn't care where the plastic comes
from it doesn't care whether a piece of
plastic is thrown from a beach here in
Britain or somewhere in Angola plastic
is plastic and the fish that get hotter
that eat it don't care so we really need
to collaborate and we need to think
about better plastics about better waste
management systems and about better
cleaning up of our rivers in our beaches
and if we do that on a global scale then
the levels of plastic as Chris also said
are probably they are high but what's to
come is even worse so really we need to
make sure nothing more comes in because
your leaving is with a sense that this
is an area of science perhaps a little
implausibly which is in its infancy when
we think about the impact of this stuff
on marine life we don't really know
where it's going we going to and I think
we are we really are on that cusp of a
lot of really good research some of the
stuff at Eric's now doing that's
actually going to come through and show
us more and more information but we do
we do have an opportunity and I think as
the campaign says it isn't about
just every single action being a drop in
the ocean all of that does come together
to really make a difference and if we
think about the marine life that we're
trying to protect whales and dolphins
now our ocean engineers they're moving
nutrients around the ocean they're
actually carbon sinks we're now finding
they're actually contributing to help
mitigate our climate change issues if we
can do something to protect them we
definitely will end up protecting the
whole of the planet and ourselves and I
think with campaigns like this we have
this huge opportunity there's an
economic opportunity here in terms of
recycling reclaiming reusing actually
burning some of these plastics and those
countries like those developing
countries if we in the developed
countries can actually develop the
technologies assist them we will be
benefitting ourselves and we will be
benefiting all the marine life like the
whales and dolphins that are in the
oceans for us becomes based on an
assumption that people get it there
isn't it I just want the W out there
whether actually that might be a bit too
subtle for some people who you know as
you say I've got used to the idea of the
disposable throwaway society might there
actually be an argument that says look
if you're going to use this stuff if you
love the convenience of drinking out of
a plastic bottle using cotton bud on a
plastic stem and throwing it away
without thinking twice about it then
fine but you'll need to pay a price
taxation tax extra taxation on plastic
Goods is that a goer well I think what
we need to do is to prevent plastic from
becoming waste and working towards a
more circular economy right rather than
linear economy where a product has a
beginning and an end we don't want
plastic to become waste because when it
becomes waste then it makes its way to
the ocean to our land field it becomes a
pollutant
if plastic is recycled and used properly
and we used then then plastic in itself
is not it's not a problem it's the
single-use plastic when when you use
something once and throw it away
when you know that there is no way and
that plastics throw will last forever or
for a very long time in our environment
it there is no excuse for for single-use
there is no excuse for single-use you
could almost turn into a slogan could
new Domino Eric Chris thanks me patients
today really appreciate it thanks very
much indeed